the fourth bus sent from texas and
filled with migrants arriving in
washington d.c this morning 10 migrants
dropped off just steps from capitol hill
this all part of governor greg abbott's
plan to get washington to make the
problem of illegal immigration more
urgently and the federal government
better move fast because the number of
border encounters since biden took off
is hitting its highest mark this march
with 221 303 encounters and remember
title 42 is set to expire in just 37
days what's going to happen once it's
gone more are expected to cross of
course and some could even be flown to
white plains new york these photos the
new york post released yesterday showing
migrants touching down at the
westchester county airport just north of
new york city before boarding buses and
heading off into the night
this route was grounded sometime after a
video was released last fall exposing
the operation which one contractor said
was on the down low but clearly it seems
to be back up and running
so let's get to it david i'll begin with
you because title 42 is set to go away
the byte administration clearly not
listening to other democrats who are
warning that things are going to get
worse especially heading into these
warmer months
right and you know those democrats
really are protecting their seats in
congress or in the senate they don't
care about the issue if they actually
did they would have done something over
the decades they've been there and
nothing's really been done about this
issue something that we need to pay
attention to with these resumed flights
are the organizations that are involved
here you've got i arrow which is the
largest government contractor they even
have a huge operation at miami
international airport and they are
operators for the government flying
people all over the country along with
other contractors also it's easter
weekend a lot of people are going to
church the lutheran church heavily
involved in this catholic charities
heavily involved in this there are other
organizations like endeavor out of
austin texas so to the american people
start asking those questions not of the
elected officials but also of your
church leaders why the churches are
involved in
basically human trafficking there's no
other way to put it this administration
with the number of interdictions what
will happen when tapachula the ant
operation with 73 000 meets all the
other interdictions and then you add the
god aways we're we see human trafficking
child trafficking women being abused i
mean talk about all the issues that are
there the american people need to ask
the people they can reach with those
questions
you know nicole the former acting dhs
deputy secretary ken cuccinelli
addressed exactly what david is talking
about here take a listen
the
roots that the cartels use and remember
who manages the border it isn't the
federal government of the united states
it's the drug cartels of mexico
they run
their human smuggling operation through
the exact same channels that they run
their drug smuggling operation through
well there are some estimates that the
drug cartels are now making more money
from
human smuggling than from drug smuggling
and no one federal government or states
including texas is doing anything to
stop that flow
nicole this is a multi-layered crisis
down there well alicia absolutely and
you know my home state is arizona along
the southwest border and my mother is
the clinical site director for homes
that does provide therapy and housing
for some of these human smuggling
victims but it really is just the
epitome of american political hypocrisy
alicia what's going on right now we
continue to send billions of dollars
worth of aid to foreign nations even
across oceans but yet at the same time
in parallel what we are doing are we are
removing the things that are in place
right now for our own borders for our
own illegal crossing that comes with
repercussions listen children have
suffered throughout covid teen overdose
deaths have doubled in the last year and
a lot of that is due to fentanyl and it
is because of an accidental overdose
because they get drugs off the street
they are laced with this illegal
fentanyl much of it which comes through
the southwest border and children die
and now i can tell you title 42 was
enacted it was a 1944 public health
emergency law that was put in place to
to decrease the amount of communicable
diseases well you know what overdose
deaths overdose in general that is also
a public health crisis and we need to
stop only thinking of covid we need to
stop just thinking of viruses that can
be transmitted what about our children
who are dying every single day more
children and young adults have died from
overdose in the last couple of years
than they have of covid let's keep that
in perspective yeah absolutely
absolutely heartbreaking as well um and
joe you know our own lawrence jones um
has been down to the border multiple
times most recently talking with
migrants at the border take a listen
where did you guys come from
mexico
how long have you been on the road
almost like a week a week
y'all just got lost
[Music]
when you got to america who are you
going to stay with uh
and we need to figure it out because
mexico is difficult
you can watch the rest of lawrence's
trip to the border airing tonight on
lawrence jones cross country at 10 p.m
eastern so watch out for that but joe
can i get your reaction there because
this is one conversation one moment one
point on the border
sure and maria bartoromo of fox business
has also gone down to the border and had
similar conversations like this and
they're all very similar and look we're
looking now at the possibility of almost
5 million people crossing the u.s
southern border illegally in just the
first two years of joe biden's
presidency alone
if this pace keeps up and there's no
reason to believe you know why it won't
right i mean you have a border czar and
kamala harris she is an absentee
landlord she doesn't even talk about
this anymore the president himself
refuses to visit the border the head of
the department of homeland security in
mayorcus is an inept buffoon carrying
out a political agenda and doing nothing
to protect the homeland his job right so
think about that what is five million
illegal migrants like what is that in
context you take the city of denver
right which is a major city has all the
major professional sports teams you
multiply their total population their
current population by now
by seven seven we've now uh we're now on
pace to add seven denver's to our
country meanwhile as nicole rightly
points out opioids particularly fentanyl
is the leading cause of death for those
between the ages of 18 and 49 in this
country it is produced in china it comes
through mexico and we have an
administration that is now allowing its
citizens to be killed at an alarming
rate who won't do anything about it
because it doesn't benefit them
politically it's an absolute joke alicia
i wouldn't mind seven denver's if they
were exactly like this but i totally see
your point there joe um it is and and
when you start talking about you know
the amount of drugs coming across and
then as nicole brings up the fentanyl
crisis we're dealing with uh it truly is
heartbreaking and troubling that the
administration isn't listening to those
experts at the border or those in their
own party
thank you so much hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else